we reached 700,000 subscribers on
YouTube yesterday as many of you know
but as many of you don't know this
program is on YouTube there's an audio
podcast were on nearly 200 radio and
television stations syndicated were on a
free speech TV which is a satellite
television channel that airs on DirecTV
and on Dish Network YouTube has been in
an important platform for us for many
years we now have achieved 700,000
subscribers and this is a huge and
absolutely awesome accomplishment thanks
to you it unfortunately is happening at
maybe the worst time ever but I'll
explain that in a moment I was looking
back at some really interesting numbers
and in our first month on YouTube we had
30 subscribers okay after a full month
on YouTube we had 30 subscribers I
pulled some data
it took us 32 months to get to 10,000
subscribers 32 almost 3 years to get to
10,000 subscribers to get from 10,000 to
a hundred thousand it took us only 30
months to get from 100 to 200 thousand
it took us only 17 months to get from
200 to 300 thousand it took us 11 months
I think you see the trend to get from
300 to 400 thousand subscribers it took
us eight months from 400 to 500,000 it
took us ten months things slowed down
but then to go from 500 to 600 it took
us seven months and we got from 600,000
to 700,000 subscribers in only four
months where would we be today if
hundreds of people were not unsubscribed
by some kind of glitch in the youtube
system from our Channel I continue to
get dozens of emails every single week
from people who say David I've been
subscribed for years I wasn't seeing
your videos I went to your channel
homepage
I wasn't subscribed so irie so that gets
to why I said this is an awesome
accomplishment but not at a very good
time we are growing the number of
subscribers on the YouTube channel very
quickly at a time when YouTube is the
priority
heisting independent news and politics
content in favor of corporate legacy
media channels not good
YouTube is increasingly D monetizing our
videos even when people watch them very
often the videos don't have ads playing
meaning that we lose the revenue on
those videos a new one that I haven't
even opened the door about is that
YouTube is now branding a lot of our
content and other news in politics
content as adult or sensitive where you
have to confirm that you actually want
to see the clip which simply reduces the
number of people who watch stuff any
barrier you put in place between a
person and a piece of content no matter
how trivial it appears to be reduces the
number of people that watch it so again
if you're not subscribed if you are
watching on youtube right now and you
scroll down and the subscribe button is
enabled press the subscribe button okay
support us directly if you can with
700,000 subscribers
imagine if 2% signed up for membership
or patreon this is the best way to
support programs you like go to WWE at
medCom pick up a membership okay if 2%
of you do that we are winning Bigley you
can use the coupon code half 19 to drop
your membership cost by 50% and or a
throw us a dollar a month on patreon go
to patreon.com/scishow one dollar a
month is great two dollars a month is
fantastic imagine if just 2 or 3 percent
of our audience gave us a dollar a month
on patreon wouldn't that be a great
thing so the big picture message the
YouTube channel is growing Bigley when
it comes to subscribers we are doing our
best to deal with all the other
challenges happening but thanks to
everybody I mean it's been it's been
years and now I do think the next big
goal is a million at this point yes
we'll talk about 800 thousand we will
talk about 900 thousand but a million is
the goal don't know when it'll happen
but you can get us one closer by
subscribing on YouTube it costs nothing
click that subscribe button